hello everybody
good morning
i just uh signed a request to congress
for critical security economic and
humanitarian assistance
uh to help ukraine continue to counter
putin's aggression
and at a very pivotal moment
we need this bill to support ukraine in
this fight for freedom and our nato
allies our eu partners they're going to
pay their fair share of the cost as well
but we have to do this we have to do our
part as well leading the alliance now
the cost of this fight
is not cheap
but caving new aggression is going to be
more costly if we allow it to happen
we either back ukrainian people as they
defend their country or
we stand by as the russians continue
their atrocities and aggression in
ukraine
every day
every day the ukrainians pay for the
price with the price they pay for their
lives for this fight
so we need to contribute arms funding
ammunition and the economic support to
make their courage and sacrifice have
purpose so they can continue this fight
and do what they're doing
it's critical this funding gets approved
and approved as quickly as possible
you know long before russia lost to
launch its brutal invasion
i i made clear how the united states
would respond
predicted they would invade and they
surely did
we said we not send u.s troops to fight
russian troops in ukraine but we would
provide
robust military assistance and try to
unify the western world against russia's
aggression
i said i would impose powerful sanctions
on russia and that we destroy and
develop we destroy
this myth that somehow they could
continue to move without the rest of the
world acting
that we deploy additional forces to
defend nato territory particularly in
the east along the russian and belarus
borders
that's exactly that's exactly what we
said we would do and we did but despite
the disturbing rhetoric coming out of
the kremlin the facts are plain for
everybody to see
we're not attacking russia we're helping
ukraine defend itself against russian
aggression
and just as putin chose to launch this
brutal invasion
he could make the choice to end this
brutal invasion
russia is the aggressor no if ends or
buts about it russia is the aggressor
and the world must and will hold russian
accountable
russia continues assault on as yielding
immense human cost
we've seen
we've seen them leave behind horrifying
evidence of their atrocities and war
crimes
and the areas they try to control
and as long as the assaults and
atrocities continue we're going to
continue to supply military systems i
might know parenthetically
you know there's a dinner this weekend
uh celebrate the press
think of what the american press has
done
the courage is taken
to stay
in these war zones the courage has taken
the report every single day
i've always had respect for the press
but i can't tell you how much respect i
have watching
watching them in these zones where
they're under fire
risking their own lives to make sure the
world hears the truth
imagine if we weren't getting that
information
it'd be a different world it'd be a
different circumstance
in the past two months russia launched
this brutal attack has moved weapons and
equipment to ukraine that we've moved
we've moved weapons and equipment and to
ukraine in record speed
thanks to the aid we've provided russian
forces have been forced to retreat from
key doesn't mean they're not going to
try to come back but they've retreated
thus far we've sent thousands of
anti-armor anti-missiles helicopters
drones grenade launchers machine guns
rifles radar systems
more than 50 million rounds of
ammunition
the united states alone has provided ten
anti-armor systems for every russian
tank that is in ukraine ten to one
providing ukraine significant timely
intelligence to help them defend
themselves against the russian onslaught
and we're facilitating a significant
flow of weapons and systems of ukraine
from our allies and partners around the
world including tanks artillery and
other weapons
that support is moving with
unprecedented speed
much much of the new equipment we've
announced
in the past two months two weeks has
already gotten to ukraine where it can
be put to direct use on the battlefield
however
we've almost exhausted what we call the
fancy phrase the drawdown authority that
congress authorized ukraine for
authorized ukraine in a bipartisan
spending bill last month
basically we're out of money
and so that's why today in order to
sustain ukraine as a as it continues to
fight i'm sending congress a
supplemental budget request
it's going to keep weapons and
ammunition flowing without interruption
to the brave ukrainian fighters and
continue delivering economic and
humanitarian assistance to the ukrainian
people this so-called supplemental
funding addresses the needs of the
ukrainian military during the critical
weeks and months ahead
and it begins and begins to transition
to longer-term security systems that's
going to help ukraine deter and continue
to defend against russian aggression
this assistance would provide even more
artillery armored vehicles anti-armored
systems anti-air capabilities
that have been used so effectively thus
far in the battlefield by the ukrainian
warriors
you know it's going to deliver
much-needed humanitarian assistance as
well as food water medicine shelter and
other aid to ukrainians displaced by
russians war
and provide aid for those seeking refuge
in other countries from ukraine
it's also going to help schools and
hospitals open
it's going to allow pensions and social
support to be paid to the ukrainian
people so they have something something
in their pocket
it's also going to provide critical
resources to address food shortages
around the globe
ukraine
ukraine was one of the world's largest
agricultural producers
it typically grows 10 percent of all the
wheat that's shipped around the world
putin has asserted sanctions are
blocking food from ukraine and russia
getting on the market the sanctions
we've imposed on russia simply not true
putin's war not sanctions
are impacting the harvest of food and
disrupting the movement
of that food by land and sea to nations
around the globe that need it
this funding is going to help ease
rising food prices at home as well
and abroad caused by russia's war in
ukraine it's going to help support
american farmers produce more crops like
wheat and oil seed which is good for
rural america good for the american
consumer and good for the world
and this supplemental request will use
the defense production act to expand
domestic production
and reserve and the reserve of critical
materials
materials like nickel and lithium that
have been disrupted by putin's war in
ukraine and that are necessary to make
everything from defense systems to
automobiles
and i hope congress i hope congress will
move on this funding quickly i believe
they will
i want to thank congress democrats and
republicans for the support of people of
ukraine
and next week
i will be in alabama
to visit lockheed martin plant that
manufactures the javelin anti-tank
missile we've been sending to ukraine
and to thank the american workers thank
them for producing the weapons that
helped stop russia's advances in ukraine
in cities like key
their hard work has played a critical
role in ensuring putin's strategic
failure in ukraine and they should know
that we know it
in addition to this supplemental funding
i'm also sending to congress
a comprehensive package
of uh that will enhance our underlying
effort
to accommodate the russian oligarchs and
make sure we take their
take their their ill-begotten gains
we're going to accommodate them
we're going to seize their yachts their
luxury homes and other ill-begotten
gains
of putin's kleptocrats
yeah kleptocracy and clip the guys who
are the kleptocracies
but these are bad guys
this legislative package strengthens our
law enforcement capabilities
to seize property linked to russia's
kleptocracy
it's going to create new expedited
procedures
for forfeiture and seizure of these
these properties and it's going to
ensure that when the oligarchs assets
are sold off
funds can be used directly to remedy the
harm russia caused in their help
and helped build ukraine
additionally yesterday
russia threatened two of our allies with
a cutoff of energy supplies
while america has ended all russian
fossil fuel imports because we're able
to use our vast support supply of power
in our country some european countries
have faced more challenges in reducing
the reliance on russian fuel
russia has long claimed to be quote the
reliable source of energy for the world
no matter what the differences are their
customers are always going to be
being in good shape
but these actions prove that energy is
not just a commodity that russia sells
to help meet other countries needs but a
weapon
will use to deploy against those who
stand against their aggression
let me be clear
we will not let russia intimidate or
blackmail their way out of these
sanctions
we will not allow them to use their oil
and gas to avoid consequences further
aggression
we're working with other nations like
korea japan qatar and others
to support our effort to help european
allies threatened by russia with gas
blackmail and their energy needs in
other ways
aggression
will not win
threats will not win this is just
another reminder
of the imperative for europe and the
world to move more and more of our power
needs to clean energy
in the united states we're doing that
right now
last year we developed more solar wind
and battery storage than any year in our
history enough to power 56 million
american homes earlier this month we
acted to bolster the or reliant the
reliance on our nuclear energy
facilities which generates more than
half of our carbon free power
and we're just getting started
i look at this as a serious problem but
also an enormous opportunity an
opportunity
bottom line
all these actions we've been taking
are about the truth this truth investing
in ukraine's freedom and security is a
small price to pay to punish russia and
aggression to lessen the risk for future
conflicts
you know throughout our history we've
learned that when dictators do not pay
the price for their aggression
they cause more chaos and engage in more
aggression they keep moving and the cost
the threats to america
and the world keep rising we can't let
this happen
our unity at home
our unity with our allies and partners
and a unity with the ukrainian people is
sending an unmistakable message to putin
you will never succeed in dominating
ukraine
finally
we're going to continue to deliver
critical support to ukraine
we must also not let our guard down in
our fight against covet 19 at home and
abroad
that's why i'm again urging congress to
act on my request
for 22.5 billion dollars in emergency
resources so the american people can
continue to protect themselves from kobe
19.
the reason we were so successful in the
past
is because i was able to work with drug
manufacturers to order significant
quantities of material we needed ahead
of time to get in the front of the line
without additional funding we can't
pre-order the amount of vaccines we need
and we risk losing our spot in line for
vaccines that target multiple variants
we're running out of supply for
therapeutics like anti-viral pills that
we desperately need
without additional funding we're unable
to purchase the life-saving treatment
for the american people
we've donated more vaccines and
treatments to the world than all other
nations in the world combined
if the us won't do it no one else is
really going to step up and do it
without additional funding the united
states won't be able to help stop to
spread around the world and close off
ongoing supports sources
of the supply chain disruptions
look
let's get both of these critical tasks
done
no delays no excuses just action now
now
thank you all
[Music]
watch your head man you're gonna get
hurt just turn that camera
mr president i wanted to ask what your
your message is to ukrainian refugees on
the southwest border and those that are
trying to flee ukraine from the violence
we have
made a direct means by which they can
get from europe from ukraine directly to
the united states
without going to the southern border in
the meantime in the southern border
we're trying to work through
and make sure that as an orderly process
they're able to get in but just so you
know
we have said there's no need to go to
the southern border fly directly to the
united states we set up a mechanism
whereby they can come directly with the
visa
mr president thank you how hard are you
by a growing number of russian comments
in their media and on some of their
officials painting this conflict as
actually already a conflict between nato
the us
and russia they're painting very
alarmist terms talking nuclear weapons
saying it's a life or death struggle etc
and just separate or convince us of that
lavrov himself says it's already a proxy
war not a direct war but a prophecy war
so are either those two things
true and do they worry those things
they're not true they do concern me
because it shows the desperation
that russia russia's feeling about their
abject failure and being able to do what
they set out to do in the first instance
and so uh
it uh
i think it's more of a reflection not of
the truth but of their failure
and so instead of saying that the
uh the ukrainians equipped with
some
capability to resist russian
uh forces uh are doing this they've got
to say tell their people the united
states and all of nato
is engaged in
taking out russian troops and tanks etc
so it it's number one it's an excuse for
their failure
but number two it's also if they really
mean it it's a it's
no no one should be
making idle comments about the use of
nuclear weapons or the possibility they
need to use that it's irresponsible mr
president on that
mr president back on the border uh title
42 a number of your democratic friends
are are pressuring the white house to
maintain that policy can you give us a
straight answer whether you're going to
where they're going to
heed that request or you're going to get
rid of it
i can give you a straight answer we had
proposed to
eliminate that policy
uh by the end of may the court has said
we can't so far
and what the court says we're going to
do the court could come along and say we
cannot do that and that's it
you think that this is not a proxy war
but russia clearly disagrees they say
that war means war so how concerned are
you that they may start to act
accordingly even if you disagree
we are prepared for whatever they do
what options do you have to ensure
poland and bulgaria have sufficient
supplies of gas
first of all as you know
poland has indicated they have
significant reserves of gas that they
have planned for
as does not as much but as does bulgaria
and we have worked with our allies from
japan on to say that we may divert our
sale of the natural gas that we're
sending to those countries and divert it
directly to uh to
poland and
bulgaria so i
you know that's as much as i can tell
you right now sir how concerned are you
about a recession given the gdp reports
today showed a contraction of one point
four percent of the fourth quarter
well i'm i i'm not concerned about a
recession and i mean you're always
concerned about
a recession but the gdp
you know fell to 1.4 percent but here's
the deal
we also had last quarter consumer
spending and business investment and
residential investment increased at
significant rates both
for leisure as well as hard products
number one number two
they we are unemployment's the lowest
rate since 1970
a record 4.5 million businesses were
created last year
we're in a situation where
the uh you know we have a very different
view than uh senator scott of
republicans
that want to raise taxes on the middle
class families and want to include half
the small business owners and that we so
i think we're
what you're seeing is enormous growth in
the country
that was affected by
everything from covet and the covert
blockages that we occurred along the way
now you always have to be
take a look and no one is predicting
every session now they're predicting
some are predicting there may be a
recession in 2023.
um i'm concerned about it but i know one
thing that you know if our republican
friends are really interested in doing
something about
dealing with
economic growth and
they should help us continue to lower
the deficit which we've done last year
over 350 billion dollars
they should be willing to work with us
to have a tax code that is actually one
that uh
um
works and everybody pays their fair
share
and they should be uh in a position
where
you shouldn't be raising taxes on
middle-class folks you should be raising
taxes on people who
everyone acknowledges that the vast
majority republicans aren't paying their
fair share i've said it 100 times
you have
you know 50 major corporations of the
fortune 500 companies made 40 billion
dollars last year didn't pay a single
penny
no one under our proposal anything in
our 400 000 a year will see a penny in
their taxes go up not one penny
do you think copenhagen and ukraine age
we tied together in legislation well i
don't care how they tie how they do it
i'm sending them both up i mean they can
do it separately or together but we need
them both mr president uh shorty leader
schumer said yesterday that you're quote
getting closer to using executive
authority to cancel up to 50 000
in a student loan debt can you confirm
that what exactly are you looking to
plan to do here in the coming you mean
my spokesman said that
majority leaders shooting yeah
um look uh
number one uh one first thing we did was
reform the system that was in place that
didn't work for anybody
that allowed people to write off debt if
they engaged in public service we have
almost a million 785 don't hold me the
exact number i'll get the number 700
some thousand have had debt forgiven
their whole debt forgiven because of
their work working in these as teachers
or other means by which they qualify and
we continue to make that easier secondly
i am considering
dealing with some debt reduction i am
not considering 50 000 debt reduction
but i'm in the process of taking a hard
look at whether or not
there are gonna there will be additional
debt forgiveness and uh i'll have an
answer on that in the next couple weeks
thank you
thank you guys thank you guys thank you
you